all right so let's talk about the six ed
box
Ray Kurzweil talks about the six a box
of evolution as leading us inexorably
towards a technological singularity with
crescendo an orgasm of cosmic proportion
he talks about epic one physics in
chemistry information stored in atomic
structures we move on then to epic to
biology information stored in DNA we
then get to epic three great information
stored in the neural patterns we then
we've to add for technology information
stored in our tools and software
programs then we move to F on five
currently living through today the
merger of biology and technology the
extension of our cognition outsourcing
to our technological tools the creation
of the imine the symbiosis between man
and machine that turns us into something
far greater which eventually gets us to
unlock six complete flourishing of
nanotechnology and biotechnology we
impregnate the universe with
intelligence we merge with all the
matter in the universe and the universe
essentially wakes up tell me that that
is not an intoxicated idea kind of idea
that inspired Alan Harrington to say in
my mind having created the gods we can
turn into them
you